let's go with the starter Steph I need a
big weight little Chris Hayden Andrew
all right nice to meet you I'm big Chris
so for talented estate agents we are and
very talented amateur cooks right yes
estate agents having the most amazing
reputation for being great bullshitters
tonight there can be no [ __ ] tonight
we're gonna look like a boss I'm gonna
deliver
okay guys come here let's do this
together any question as we go along
please have really appreciative you ask
yeah what you got in here
sage onion the potatoes don't flood it
with butter otherwise it goes too soggy
okay nice and flat push it on the side
yeah so this is called a potato rosti
basically a nice sort of crispy potato
cake yes Chinese cooked so doesn't take
that long I've been careful you don't
catch it
yeah I don't see it burning okay thanks
make sure you don't break the yolk guys
very very quiet no questions black
pudding it's cooked already it's already
made yeah it's nice and spicy sweet
slice he's proportion turn it over
let your black pudding rest right so far
so good yes so first off
Teddy cake nice your mayor's eggs out on
black pudding over when you mix the
black pudding and the egg yolk yeah it's
delicious yeah a little bit of solids
just the top of the plate wait wait put
a vinaigrette over the paper step oh
we're good
Table nine yeah let's go guys yes right
listen up for customers table one please
yeah poor pudding for Peter Scott for
tiramisu
yes sure let's go guys yeah I was
waiting for this [ __ ]
but yogi first oh all right Oh chef Zoe
sorry just [ __ ] changing this all
right [ __ ] you Nell keeps on breaking it
[ __ ] you know so a stupid [ __ ] it
Christo's because we'd spy against you
know what I'm doing another one
you just straight off the stove yeah
like would you eat that
quick Chris the best thing to do like we
showed your pan like that and just slide
off but yeah this is such a simple
starter I usually every one of you I
came up doing this but right now roll
over the shoulders turn the cake on the
play only let's go
so what about what about Chris break
eggs please I'll put a tape on the
finger don't burst the yes definitely
seller please with an extra with net why
didn't we just see in there watch me
shake shake video and muscles at the
bottom result just watch roll round you
know dance yeah [ __ ] the dance naturally
no please Chris yeah there we go
so this please no longer waited yes
table 14 sorry about the delay
okay cell 14 let's go chanting you
this lot are convinced they can [ __ ]
cooked never ever trust a state agent
[Music]
being a share being a buildup you have
to work for your money
whereas I could pick up a couple of
phone calls and I've made my 6000 pound
there's opportunity to make a little
money I'm motivated by money and success
the way I see it everyone is bricks on
walk off everyone's out there to make
money as a team we're very good at
cooking you know baby sweet corn your
peppers your chickens if he's like that
it's a challenge like losing my hands I
like to be busy stop diner and Trump
here sir if anyone's gonna wind up good
than the most Scott be Steph Steph he
doesn't mean to you just will I can't
take orders from anyone we're gonna be
the best 45 minutes of God gets on you
we serve four tables move your ass a
little bit yeah
oh man good to see you welcome lady G
how are we enjoy the starter don't know
how to meet it would you pay for it yeah
I paid for that hey bouncing in here
yeah in a CAF no sumup you won't get
food like that in a cab you get sausages
with it
did you understand the menu because I
devised a little easy format menu
something to make me feel less
intimidated pictures of the site
explanation how'd you know as much as
you choked
I found that veal was a baby camel in
general you actually quite fussy eater
aren't you I'm not fussy you're
demanding no no cheese no fruit no it's
no no cheese no onions no it's Manzo's
no mushrooms right now sadly thank you
now very most are roses [ __ ] [ __ ]
well yeah you you you you know you eat
well what's that what they might taste
no I don't eat lot I really don't that
but I do what I do we is is not that
great for me shocker
the main course enjoyed the start yes
absolutely it was very happy I don't
know about the rest of these they're
very tight no
personally I think that egg was well
overcooked the start was okay but it was
something that I've become a bit better
okay results for the starters let's go
what you reckon 20 with you 5 25 25 25
number of customers are prepared to pay
for the starter
[ __ ] out 14 only 14 hour 15 yeah
I wouldn't laugh there's nothing funny
about that
36 customers refused to pay yeah
what to normal [ __ ] and the egg or all
of the cuts of the Rings unbelievable
yeah so far that is the worst score ever
seriously yeah [ __ ] that's it you can
come back here shed you know don't worry
can come back from there that very wrap
there's my girlfriend get 54 main yes
next on the menu my son Jack goes from
boy to action man let me think you're in
line great forward and pull the trigger
yeah it's time for the main course a
delicious fearless scallop with caponata
and the heat is on for Chris Moyles yes
welcome back the effort now is never too
early to teach your son about birds
I'm taking Jack often its first ever
foodie adventure in search of something
that we really stopped eating a rook
rook PI is an Old English classic but
today it's almost entirely forgotten
that's a shame because thousands of
rooks are shot every spring
they've become a real pest damaging
crops and stealing other birds eggs
you're scared about going in The
Woodlands
you're like an action man like that will
be shooting the gamekeeper Dave Whitby
an old mate of mine who's got a problem
with rooks on his land welcome good to
see you mate good to see you first time
ever shooting a gun yes
excited yeah want to go back in call
Molly no let's go buddy pound how about
you miss yes that's enough when you
think you're in line reach forward and
pull the trigger
yeah good shot you got the target
you ready for another one more take
careful aim when you're ready that's two
pounds oh you know Jack's a chip off the
old block but today it will be me
shooting the rooks we're heading into
the woods where the bird's nest the
traditional way to call rooks is to
shoot the young as they leave their
nests okay buddy load me up please
Oh give me five don't miss that just up
through there safety catch off yeah all
right see if you can spot me jack okay
good man good man excellent good shot
thanks buddy
see ya good sure there's not much meat
on a rook so we'll need at least six to
feed the three of us how exciting is
this buddy right good one just London
through here my good Jack may not be old
enough to hunt for real but he makes a
damn good gun dogs gonna have blood on
there let's go stop acting like a girl
wait is good Oh amazing
huh yeah okay Robin good bad
[Music]
I've never eaten Brooke before so I have
no idea what it tastes like but with a
little TLC we can bring this forgotten
food back to people's plates but listen
mate you're doing a great job there you
know that huh this is liver yeah we
could eat that as well no and there's
its heart there though
hang upside down I sit on his breast
like that from there don't watch turn it
round and then we're just gonna take the
breast off there okay there we go
see ya but that smaller breast is it huh
we're gonna do something very simple
just a really nice rook son is almost
like a pigeon salad with green beans
spring onions beetroot and a hazelnut
vinaigrette so I'm gonna sort of lightly
marinades the rook first some salt and
pepper on there please
lassic and rub the garlic over that
feature now a little bit of hazelnut oil
and a little bit of sherry vinegar now
get your fingers in there
nice nice no good while the rook
marinades it's time to the salad green
beans beetroot spring onion and oak leaf
lettuce good drain the beans and add
some salt hazelnut oil and coriander
smells yeah absolutely do behind ready
for the road yes
okay so touch of olive oil in it very
very quickly
Wow three seconds for the rest of the
marinade in there as well
thank you
you don't want any rope cause you didn't
like do you know he does
[Music]
they're not more tender than I thought
they would be now this for me is as good
as if not better in the pigeon it just
looks like a bit of Venice yeah I think
it's about time there's something like
this bird Brooke should find his way
back on traditional British menus yeah
absolutely I'm I'm truly surprised how
good that was
you happy with yours yeah that was
delicious now it's time to forget to
take on the main course god help me
[Music]
it's got up a veil caponata it's
delicious it's very lean it's good for
you and it's a great alternative to
beasts now caponata basically it's like
a ratatouille but without all the tomato
puree so you can identify exactly what's
in it chopped peppers celery onions over
jeans now it's really important to have
something like no gene inside a caponata
it gives you that sort of bittersweet
flavor hot pan olive oil seasoned
[Applause]
[Music]
red wine vinegar and that sort of waked
everything up tomato
basil olives capers lovely smells
amazing out onto a plate
and that stops it from overcooking I'm
telling mush Wow it's got up a bill now
we're gonna panning it basically that
means flour egg wash and bread crop
three very simple stages put the
tablespoons of flour eggs bread crumbs
Parmesan but these will take it to a
different dimension
[Music]
a nice heavy coating of breadcrumbs and
Parmesan cheese prevents the field from
drying out and now she's ready for the
pan olive oil just to start to smoke and
she goes I love that sound if it goes
into a cold pan with olive oil you've
got these scalloped greasy we only turn
it once it can rip or tear quite easily
check the color Wow now this is where it
gets really exciting pine nuts
capers butter that helps to toast the
pine nuts fry off the capers and really
give the most amazing flavor basil
adora butter will start to cook the
basil
caponata be generous with it
well
then with a veil up and on
summers here B let's call it with
caponata done right pasta it's a very
fine spaghetti it's already cooked so
just reheating it yes in literally 30
seconds on hot plate let's go okay
parsley running through their top of the
plate fresh pasta
on the veil goes on when you make 50
portions like that
you will have the biggest comeback ever
okay yes full meal away let's go
like we're not [ __ ] this up have to
season it first season the veal so chef
yeah how's that season the Vil that's
right yeah
have you tasted little critters in there
no can we [ __ ] watch the pants boo
they're all on fire now yes guys touched
it I'm just dealing with a bill please
leave the place then guys at least show
that you care a little [ __ ] bit yeah
service please yes let's go guys
all restaurants full of smoke the
[ __ ] windows yeah before the
customers choke to death yeah please
I didn't need to be that [ __ ] hard
seriously did not need to be that hard
clear down guys
nabil is quite soggy so it's not got
that kind of nice light Chris penis
around it it's quite wet and a bit sort
of stodgy on the plate
I like the capers and the olives with
the veal it was really nice yeah I'd
definitely have it again I'm not
particularly enjoying it it's the the
fearless woefully soggy it's like a
piece of like wet brillo pad result just
make all this go quickly right step how
do you think you did and I feel we did
that badly 25 Fay and that's not bad for
you more after 14 I think Jen five or
thirty he's bad Betsy
Michael's okay out of 50 how many cuts
was paid for the main course
21 what decided to pay [ __ ] me that's
not bad
that [ __ ]
right here we go again
enjoy the Michaels yeah lovely yes yeah
I'm supposed to [ __ ] got it yeah an
absolute nightmare in there stages I
thought they had a look of Tasha's about
them I liked it but I wasn't sure what
ever there was right the caponata kept
an Italian version of like a ratatouille
but without the heavy Tomatoes Wyatt was
like a Charlie Brown I just okay okay
now you cleaned up your food who could
say yeah no [ __ ] how often do you
have two takeaways
sometimes away I want to say four four
times a week I've got a surprise for you
yes I'm not phoning them please don't
upset
I won't upset that I pie is called
Ramsay I'm calling on behalf on your
regular customers mr. Chris Moyles do
you know him what does he know we take
away what is it the chicken curry no is
that right yeah mr boo right now I'd
like to place the exact same order
delivered to their forward restaurant
listen I'll give you a 20-pound tip if
you get here within 20 minutes okay yeah
okay thank you right this is a challenge
no I'm serious I'm gonna show you before
he gets it that will cook together yeah
when now right delicious
fast food curry yay let's go right
ginger chilies garlic lemongrass right
all into there just pour on it
poor Lauren okay yes
of lemongrass so we're gonna make your
local curry paste okay check it in but
I'm doing exactly the same you know that
okay exactly the same lime leaves in soy
sauce in how much 20 minutes up what's
that
seriously can what is that this cinnamon
stick okay okay
chicken yes okay right smell that
what is this Mel cream come on
coconut milk okay and she goes no are
you happy with that
yeah whatever these right there green
beans yes right that just gives it a
little bit of sort of body but I put
them all in I'm not don't cut your
fingers off right now okay look yeah
chop it now handle not cut your fingers
[Laughter]
playin okay come on okay listen Tori's
nearly go
okay now and then look I'm watching yeah
just all in there okay okay okay okay
one quick nut bring April on come on I
break the quick the challenge bring the
plate man that's the challenge with the
place okay okay oh dear oh dear well
done yeah you know
[Applause]
let's see what's in there chicken curry
no onion you should also get a free Papa
jungle is there free Papa Tom in there
there is yeah okay we got vertex now
side by side okay okay
hi I just write it so you have a taste
and you as well I cook this by the way I
don't know I'm gonna wait for God's
reaction fry is it Matt is nice really
seriously don't get me bad you know it's
nice but very greasy but mr. Moore loves
anyway doesn't it I have to say I
actually prefer the one you make
thank you I'm Suzy and right it's a lot
easier lot quicker and just think good
food mmm can be made faster and better
than a takeaway yes I did I you you did
I know yes yeah okay yes next on the
menu builders put their junk food ways
behind them and I want to show you my
tool now yeah
it's time for dessert an Italian classic
tiramisu and comedienne Meera Syal
is hot stop in the recipe challenge and
it's great instantaneous actually sexy
grandma
welcome back the effort okay so first
builders doing things quickly we all
think that builders unlace er slackers
who are always on a tea break so when I
heard there were three builders from
Essex that were constantly whinging the
fact that they never had chance to eat
properly or cook for themselves I had to
meet them
these boys rip out and replace kitchens
across Essex and they reckon this leaves
them no time to cook or eat properly
[Music]
just pop pies chocolate bars crisps you
just really don't get the time to go out
there and get saying sorry I've proper
basis it's always a case newest location
where you're working that's where you're
gonna go and it would love golden to
help us create some ink ideally within
half an hour to keep us on fire
throughout the day
everyone's got time to cook if I've got
the right recipes and I mean everyone
Essex builders and the proper leavening
a [ __ ] bacon sandwich will sit on
their ass gentlemen good morning how are
we
Charlie good to see you all down Larry
all right nice to see it Oh Mike Gary
Gary how are you so why have you got
reputation be such lazy [ __ ] oh this
is not some you know building site where
if you are sitting on your ass in the
poet cabin or something you can get away
with it right how long would it really
seriously take to rip the kitchen out
without any tea breaks or bacon yeah
yeah about an hour maximum I'd like to
see how difficult it is with me in our
kitchen I'd like to become a proper
builder
[Music]
just fighting I can get my hammer for at
that box first play my hammer fault yeah
[ __ ] me what is a hammer for PG tipps
well you know just doing this because I
mean it's very everyday your [ __ ]
graph says you work your ass off yet
you're [ __ ] abusing yourselves I want
to show you my tool now my talk is a
powerful guest over in the builders tent
there's still half an hour demolishing
left to do so I'm going to show the
rubble brothers that they can cook a
delicious lunch in less than 25 minutes
got much time yeah we'll do a very quick
easy beef stew
[Music]
onions garlic thyme star letís see the
omelet the secret behind this sissies
one pot says like a one pot wonder yeah
yeah
I gave you my simple philosophy no color
no flavor reason why I've cut them into
small chunks like that it's to cook it
faster but these guys have better get a
move on
I am NOT gonna be beaten by a builder
with a bump crack big enough to park a
bike in tablespoon of tomato puree so
creme fraiche it just lines up a little
bit amazing how quick it comes together
Gary be working on the money together
you'd never get this quality food from a
cycle I know okay I can't believe you
cook this Mike yeah I'm going back to my
own kitchen now first yeah this that's
for you guys yeah I want it in the back
of the van always to use it turn on get
it hot put your pan on and cook yeah yes
definitely
I've always wanted a drum machine so
okay steamer soup
stick to your purse work together let's
go sugar now yes yes let's go yes enough
vanilla masala yep yeah good right cream
in let's go you continue with skin cream
in let's go
Steph taste it yes little crispy the
back piece is set for dessert an Italian
classic
[Music]
tiramisu basically pick me up that's
what it means in Italian but it's easy
simply delicious and very very fast we
split it into two balls mascarpone put
that into the bowl and just let it go
nice and soft in the next bowl 150 ml of
cream icing sugar
wisk
that's really important that we don't
overlook this cream we're just looking
like a nice sort of thick lava
consistency no more than that
already within seconds it's got nice and
sort of light and soft but he'll extract
now we use an extract over fresh trailer
because it gives a very nice sort of
dense dark color Marsala wine
it's got a really nice sort of cafe au
lait color now on the cream coffee now
it's really important that coffee is
ice-cold just add in thirds don't add it
all straight away
[Applause]
folding that cream on oyster sugar
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's a really nice light tumor suit
that is fast and sets within 20 minutes
of rich bold coffee ladies fingers and
just into the coffee turn them round and
out again so what happens now there's
sodium outside still nice and crispy in
the center
take your martini glass fingers in
be generous with it
frig 20 minutes chocolate great nice
little shots and then finally
cocoa powder
[Applause]
[Music]
these Italian tiramisu with ladies
fingers done yes Chris for to Monsieur
way that's Gary try not to [ __ ] it up
please that Jonah did a pretty much idea
I'm gonna dip and get this ready for you
presentation for a white big Chris let's
go pour away away be careful not to lock
see their combat really soggy you
wouldn't come out to really hot I mean
the most important thing about this
challenge is get it out fast now yes
please
come on give it some formalization going
now they should be flying hours actually
nothing cooked guys you just put it
together now just put it in a glass go
please double 14 guys goes myself that
to me service from her it's not good
I've been here for seven hours I'm
starving
to Mercy dessert was absolutely gorgeous
really light and fluffy and I love the
the moist biscuit it was it was really
really stunning really really loved it
got some and your mouth
[Music]
now goodness gracious me Meera Syal is
going to try and beat me in the recipe
challenge ready as I'll ever be
now you're cooking something authentic
yes yes I'm cooking my my third kadal
Dhaka doll yeah it's a kind of staple of
Punjabi dish yeah very much a thing but
the idea is that you stake the dish and
I have to come up with my own version of
it so I'm gonna do a vegetable korma and
some will use lentils and squash
aubergine carrot and you're gonna have
what in yours basically tomatoes lentils
and spices it's very basic fantastic I
cannot believe I'm cooking vegetarian my
god why did you choose this particular
dish I cook it's a lot it's a real
favorite with the family and of course
lentils are really really good for you
does it make you fart yeah really badly
well not me I'm amazing I don't do that
yeah why is that ladies don't fart we
don't pass it's never never we blow our
nose it's very literally we were well
the air that way my wife barks and then
she blames the children which is so
unfair
yeah children are very useful for that
honor and dog fantastic I'm so glad
we're talking about bottom things are we
cooking this is lovely
no no now my god your ring is enormous
Mira dear oh dear
goodness gracious me my ring is enormous
thank you for that my darling right what
are you doing there I'm basically frying
up the ginger garlic cumin seeds and
mustard seeds but you're going to form
the basis of without you have to really
make sure that cumin seeds are cooked
when it's at least two minutes and if
you want to cook them and make quite a
bitter taste in the dal so they're gonna
be quite careful with them now in here
garlic ginger shallots I'm just gonna
make a very quick sort of paste and
blend them to help to thicken the korma
and give it some sweetness
what those pies you put in there my
darling and I'm putting in garam masala
and ground coriander
lovely now I'm using a masala as well
it's the all-purpose spice oh yes what
lens was you use in there I'm using a
mixture of red lentil and flipmunk I
find that mung on its own is very watery
yeah and if you mix them the red lentils
are a bit firmer to get a nice firm
consistency so onions mustard seed star
anis and cinnamon stick now that's just
to infuse the oil just to get everything
going in a way that we're sort of
getting it nice and spicy and making the
foundation and I'm going to pop in a
whole green chilli Oh whole rather
that's a very large one yes have you
ever been in an Indian kitchen and
actually cooked I live in a blatant
ending kitchen what do I need to go to
one in a restaurant no no nobody to have
you doing the rest my whole childhood
watching my mom and my aunt's is good
really oh yes and when I was really
little is that how the inspiration of
the Kumar's is at how it sort of arrived
from the family point of view absolutely
hysterical surrounded by very strong
funny women you know completely away
from the cage they have what people
think in big women are about and food
was a huge part of my childhood is a
huge part of Indian culture it's how we
connect and it look I think to my
parents as well it's how they keep home
alive when we were little it was like
soul food Indian food was like this
living connections about your home you
know that's what we should be about
foods about love isn't it family if I
couldn't love anyone that didn't love
food yep pretty no I don't like hot food
no I know that seems blasphemous for an
Indian but actually I think a lot of
what people mistake for curry yeah it's
just a whole lot of chili and not much
else and I think good Indian cooking has
layers of flavor in it is that because
you get rings thing yeah
listen it's quite common in chefs you
know that we chefs love curry
normally Friday night ya know me spread
that but you see that's the cliche it's
like yeah well good you know we'll come
out of the pub we'll have a Ruby Murray
well it's something really hot that
impress our mates and you throw it up on
the pavement outside afterwards and
that's quite an insult to what it's a
fabulous really yeah but that's that
legendary sketch isn't it sort of
overindulgent and going out for an
English what I have to say was one of
the funniest sketches I've ever seen you
can sow vegetables in butternut squash
courgettes an aubergine yeah yeah then I
put my almond paste in with a ginger she
Lawson garden oh yeah
I'm gonna add my lentils now these are
the Puy lentils wait anyway so are you
working on you series of Kumar's no.17
yeah and I suppose there is something
about going out on a high hunger and
actually I've got them again so let's
create that yeah it was fun that sort of
voice you put on now how long does it
take you to sort of you know get up to
speed with us and it's great
instantaneous actually sexy grandma so
what you'll do to you of next
combination mothers does it take to
change a light bulb I don't know don't
worry about me I'll sit in the dark
money doubles it's a face mom because
you can just put your face
pence tv-game your pores and steam away
yeah Singles finished mine with a little
touch more of coconut milk got the
tablespoons freshly chopped coriander
and then squeeze a fresh lemon in there
tell me what you do now you're putting
your garlic in there yeah it's very
simple it's just garlic tomatoes yeah
and what you call that going at that got
I think it means like sauce oh yeah
maybe they're right
they both simmer now for 20 minutes then
our blind tasters get their hands on it
and then I'm gonna win simple as that
next on the menu I take my sheep to
palatial pastures we're going to becky
nunn palace look at the size of it
you're funny very delicious but when I
find out who wins the recipe challenge
that the winner for this time yes is for
the past five weeks I've been looking
for the next great female TV cook to
fill the aprons of deer
Nigella and Fanny Cradock I've had
thousands of applications so far we use
everything that we've got in the van
that says seal in it but some stirring
to do now this will be perfect for some
people other people prefer richer
chocolate flavor there
we're making chocolate magic mountain
maidens
forfeit give me a chance on your program
an Asian Sunday
what you reckon those are some of my
favorites
- okay yeah okay good news yes how are
you lot of flavors in this one very
different I came on to me
how where that takes us and happy yeah
very cool both of them by the way it's
very close but the winner for this time
yes
he's come on stop [ __ ] around who's
the winner yes can I just say that was
delicious
and you've been an absolute star and
that's one of most exciting challenges
that ever had neither chick please
of course you can several weeks ago I
brought my cross bred lambs Charlotte
and Gavin to London soon my flock had
eating me out of house and home
scoffing over two kilos of grass and veg
every day it's damn hard were like
having a second family of vegetarians my
special sheep have been staying in Sarah
beanies garden for a couple of weeks
she's done a great job personally
ensuring that they're happy and healthy
where are they in just a few weeks time
they'll be the centrepiece of the f word
menu at Claridge's good to see my
darling
they have grown they have they do done
the grass has gone down hasn't it my god
yeah and we've been giving them a lot of
little extra tidbits very friendly and
they play football they love it
she will gorge themselves on good grass
and even Sarah's lush lawn has not been
enough
following shaggy sheep farmer huber Lee
Witt installed advice it's time to move
them up the property ladder to a new
home none of you know where they're
going yet
my grandma's know we'll be there in
about one minute who said that well done
Tilly that's right David and Victoria's
we're going to pickin and palace how
lucky are they thank you my up the zoo
with me and the Sheep thank you how cool
is that David and Victoria were in
Madrid and couldn't greet their new
guests personally and grass we were
shown round to the back garden all 17
acres of it hi guys and it's all safe
and it's all fenced off and picture a
motivate a shoe and it all checked out
make sure what I say yeah it's a big
moment time to see if my sheet will take
the new home thankfully my flock settles
quickly into the lush grass of Beckenham
palace they special have been in Wales
that will shut up super early witness
still whinging about them being in the
city yeah right I'm gonna call Victoria
say thank you first of all thank you I
mean this place I thought we're gonna
put them in a pen but we've got the
whole back garden have you say along the
grasses here
honestly I've lost my fear we can barely
see jack but you can't just say there's
an advantage having sheep [ __ ] in your
back garden you know actually fertilizes
the ground and I'm gonna miss my sheep
they've become part of the family
and now there's so much further away
from home it's going to be hard not to
worry about them okay starts us 14 our
50 mains 21 our 50 desserts
2750 of interfaith plus the illness that
is a [ __ ] embarrassment there's one
bit of good news
you're definitely definitely definitely
going back to [ __ ] Claridge's that do
me a favor
yes [ __ ] off out my kitchen yes go yes
out [ __ ] you now 62 out of 150 that is
shocking the worst by miles
[Music]